The daughter was diagnosed with low thyroid, but the only test the doctor did was a TSH.
She put her scythroid. Is that okay? I mean, I don't know this person's history or anything like that,
but no, that's not okay. If that is true, that's like the practice in my book. You don't
diagnose low thyroid on elevated TSH. So TSH is thyroid stimulating hormones,
created by the pituitary gland to tell the thyroid to screen more thyroid hormones. So when the blood
levels of T3 and T4 are low, stimulates the hypothalamus to tell the pituitary to tell the
thyroid to screen more T4. I mean, most of the hormones created by the thyroid gland is T4.
There's just about five percent. It's T3. T3 is the active four. And then T4 has to be converted
to T3 in the liver, in the gut. And that conversion can be an issue right there. So it can be converted
inadvertently to what's called reverse T3. And that can be the person's problem. So to investigate the
thyroid thoroughly, you want to run a total T3 and T4, three T3 and T4, and then a TSH,
and then a reverse T3 to see if T4 is getting converted to a bad form of T3, which is not active.
It is not beneficial and will never re-convert to active T3. And then you should run thyroglobulin
antibodies and TPO antibodies. We discussed with that other patient's question before. Because you have
to know whether you're dealing with Hashimoto's or not. So just running TSH is not adequate. And it's
not adequate to use TSH as your sole marker for use to eat a medication. I think that's just wrong.
It's just that doctorate. You have to look at T3 and T4 levels. TSH, actually, if you're in your TSH
level, let's say every hour for a day, you'd have different levels of TSH. So you can't use that
S here, S here, B, B, B.